la chapelle bleue invite à prendre place
et apprécier le temps qui passe et joly
tient au moyen des rayures
il ya déjà des petits et des petits
partis et d un petit peu plus haut il a
encore plus grand et dender plus gros
est encore floue plus gros sarivo une
autre cabane attend les visiteurs
perchées dans les arbres wind l'oeuvre
d'un argentin dénonce les dérèglements
climatiques pour conny bolitar 387
habitants cette balade est un bon moyen
pour faire connaître la commune a porté
la culture dans le milieu rural aussi ça
c'est important
accessible à tous aussi et puis c'est
faire découvrir aussi notre
environnement puisque on aidera bosse
mais on a la particularité d'avoir une
rivière donc laponie avec une jolie
vallée tout un espace vert au tout et ça
je pense que c'est ça mérite d'être
connue vie km de flânerie en 2h30 3h
dans une zone classée natura 2000
l'idée c'est aussi vraiment que je crois
pour toutes les deux estrella et moi
c'était arrivé à ce que la
l'installation on est vraiment
l'impression qu'elle soit incluse dans
le paysage qu'elle n'est pas juste posé
comme ça mais qu'elle est vraiment en
mouvance avec le paysage une ombre
s'étend sur le sentier d'art fréquenté
par cinq à six mille visiteurs les
subventions départementales sont passés
de 5000 à 500 euros cette année on a
vraiment peur de ne pas pouvoir tout
bêtement le refaire
avec des artistes professionnels ce qui
perdrait un peu de sang son intérêt car
le rappelle donc c'est un sentier d'art
contemporain avec des artistes qui
viennent de toute l'europe
donc qu'ils sont radins mrm musulmans ce
parcours d'art contemporain s'expose
tout l'été gratuitement les oeuvres de
16 artistes vous attendent jusqu'à la
rentrée